hello everyone and welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel today we have a
highly relevant and important topic to
discuss the types of cyber crimes in
this digital age where technology
empowers us it's crucial to understand
the darker side of the internet cyber
crimes in this video we'll discuss what
cyber crimes are the motive behind cyber
crimes and the different types of cyber
crimes
but before we begin if you enjoy
watching these videos and find them
interesting then subscribe to our
Channel because we bring the best videos
for you daily also hit the Bell icon to
never miss any updates from Simply loan
with cyber crimes becoming more
prevalent and sever it has become
crucial to address the cyber security
skill Gap and overcome the shortage of
cyber Talent if you're interested in
pursuing a career in cyber security and
acquiring the necessary skills then our
postgraduate program in cyber security
in collaboration with MIT University is
surely the right choice for you gain
expertise in defensive and offensive
cyber security digital forensics ethical
hacking penetration testing and other
crucial domains with this intensive
program a comprehensive program offers a
curriculum that encompasses a wide range
of in demand cyber security tools
Hands-On labs and guided practices
throughout the course you will embark on
a well structured Learning Journey
starting with the fundamental cyber
security Concepts and progressing
through asset and inventory management
Network systems Python Programming
system administration offensive security
and defensive security practices to
ensure your Readiness for the industry
you'll also engage in multiple projects
allowing you to Horn your skills and
emerge as an exceptional cyber security
professional furthermore this course
will help you learn comprehensive
approaches to protecting your
infrastructure and securing data
including risk analysis mitigation and
compliance so hurry up and find the
course Link in the description box for
more
details before we explor the various
types of cyber crimes let's grasp what
cyber crimes are and the motives behind
cyber crimes cyber crimes are malicious
activities carried out by hackers to
compromise computers networks and
sensitive information the motives can
range from financial gain political
agendas and revenge to Simply causing
chos we must be aware of these threats
to protect ourselves and our digital
assets understanding cyber crimes motive
helps develop effective cyber security
strategies to mitigate and respond to
these threats some of the most common
motives behind cyber crimes are
financial gain money is a big reason for
cyber crimes bad guys want to steal
important money related informations
like credit cards and logins they sell
this info secretly or use it to trick
others and steal their identity there's
also rent somewhere where they lock your
stuff and ask you money to unlock it
business Pine in the business World
cyber crimes can be like stealing
Secrets companies or even countries
might hack to take valuable ideas
Secrets or special information from each
other it's like peeking at someone's
notes to get ahead the third one is
politics or strong beliefs some people
use cyber crimes to show they are upset
about politics or belief they might hack
into government or company stuff to make
a statement they might mess things up or
share secret info to get attention the
fourth one is Revenge imagine someone
doing something mean to you and you want
to get back at them some cyber crimes
happen because people want revenge they
use hacking to hurt the people or groups
they are mad at the last is digital
scary stuff sometimes cyber crimes are
like online scary movies hackers can try
to scare many people by attacking
important things like power or
transportation this makes life difficult
for everyone and creates chaos now let's
dive into some of the most common types
of cyber crimes along with their
characteristics the first one is hacking
hacking involves gaining unauthorized
access to computer systems networks or
devices with the intention of obtaining
sensitive information causing damage or
disrupting Services hackers May exploit
vulnerabilities in software weak
passwords or insecure network
configuration to gain access what inside
they can steal data install malware or
even take control of systems hacking can
Target individuals businesses or
government entities and the motivations
can range from financial gain to
activism the second one is fishing
fishing is a type of cyber crime where
attackers send deceptive mails messages
or websites that appear to be from
legitimate source to trick recipents
into revealing sensitive information
such as passwords credit cards or
personal detail these messages often
create a sense of urgency or alarm to
encourage recipents to click on
malicious links or download harmful
attachments fishing attacks can lead to
identity theft Financial loss or
unauthorized account access the third
type is ransomware ransomware is a form
of malicious software that encrypts a
victim's files or entire system
rendering them inaccessible the attacker
then demands a ransom payment to provide
the decryption key ransomware attacks
can severely disrupt businesses and
individuals by preventing access to
critical data and Systems payment of the
ransom does not guarantee that the
attacker will provide their decryption
key and even if they do it encourages
the growth of this criminal activity the
next type is malware malware is a broad
category of malicious software that
includes viruses WMS Trojans and spyware
these programs are designed to infect
computers and Network Works often with
the goal of stealing sensitive
information causing damage or gaining
unauthorized access viruses and WMS
spread themselves by attaching to
legitimate files or exploiting
vulnerabilities while Trojans disguise
themselves as legitimate software
spyware is designed to secretly gather
information from a victim's device often
for the purpose of stealing personal and
financial data the last step we are
going to discuss is the identity theft
identity theft involves obtaining and
using someone else's personal
information such as their name social
security number credit card details or
bank account information without their
consent cyber criminals engage in
identity theft to commit various
fraudulent activities such as making
unauthorized purchases applying for
loans or credit cards and even
committing crimes in the victim's name
this type of cyber crime can lead to
financial run damage to credit scores
and legal issues for the victims so
these top five cyber crimes highlight
the diverse ways in which cyber
criminals exploit technology and human
vulnerabilities for financial gain
personal motives or other malicious
purposes it's important for individuals
and organizations to be vigilant adopt
strong cyber security practices and stay
informed about emerging threats to
mitigate the risks associated with these
cyber crimes now that we have covered
these cyber crimes let's discuss some
safety measures to protect ourselves
online the first is keep your software
updated regularly update your operating
system applications and antivirus
software to patch vulnerabilities that
hackers might exploit use strong
passwords create complex passwords and
use a password manager to track them
avoid using the same password across
multiple accounts enable two Factor
authentication turn on two Factor
authentication whenever possible this
adds an extra layer of security by
requiring a second verification step the
next is be cautious of suspicious links
never click on links from unknown
sources over over links to check their
destination before clicking the last is
educate yourself stay informed about the
latest cyber threats and educate
yourself on best practices to stay safe
online so there you have it a
comprehensive overview of common types
of cyber crimes and the steps you can
take to protect yourself remember
vigilance and awareness are your best
allies in the digital world before we
end this video let's take a minute hear
it out from our Learners who have
experienced massive success in their
careers through a postgraduate program
in cyber security hi I'm Phillip I'm 61
years old and last year I upskill with
simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security after working 30 years in
the it sector and various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course course I
must say was packed with practical
examples was led by highly skilled and
certified instructors I worked with many
companies before as a security analyst
and architect on a contract basis but I
needed some stability which I got with
the job I just started with infosis as a
cyber security consultant happened after
I took the course but first and foremost
I've been a learner be a learner first
so that's all for this video guys if you
find this video helpful don't forget to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
your friends if you have any questions
or doubts put them down in the comment
section below and a team of experts will
definitely answer them for you so we'll
see you next time until then keep
learning and stay tuned to Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn n up and get certified click
here